ebbene sì il giorno è arrivato e sono
pronto per una gigantesca figura di mer
e matematica la figura di merda e questa
tragedia per aver perso una sfida e dove
fare una lezione di pole dance
la trovo ridicola immotivata e tossica
figlia di una mascolinità tossica e
arriva poi sembra anche baba gianmarco
ha paura
manco di salire che tocca il soffitto
come caviglia si esca prima della
pollera appena laureata stavo studiando
per il concorso notarile per l'esame da
avvocato appena è arrivata la pole in
realtà è arrivato anche il titolo da
avvocato è stato defenestrato abbastanza
velocemente ma mente testa cominciamo
bene
[Applauso]
[Risate]
[Musica]
francesca mi piace mi sembra una che
ispira fiducia però stesso tempo e lo
stesso sorriso di chi sta per mettere
nel q2
francesca è simpaticissima per secondo
me ti dice brano anche se in realtà fi
altamente cacare vi chiedo in anticipo
già scusa per quello che andrete a
vedere perché potrebbe essere poco
sostenibile
sì
[Musica]
grazie
o il bravo
salire sul po il palo è un bullo b1 poi
non riesco a trovare un modo diverso
certo fa male tutto mi sono ritrovato
con un falò è un barbecue sotto ricordò
dopo questa operazione di vaginoplastica
magari dimentico la e lato vi è nessun
lampo pagano
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma grazie
[Musica]
la morte
di notte aveva già marco sul palo è come
lo immaginavo forte capace riesce a fare
tutte quante le figure ma sembrano degli
origami sbagliati
guglielmo devo dire bene me lo aspettavo
ma tempo montato la testa e si sente il
pole dancer mi dici salì sul palo guarda
trovo più difficile farti un caffè per
quanto mi riguarda mi dici sederti sul
palo io mi siedo su quel palo con tutto
che ho i [ __ ] infuocati mi dici
ribaltati facciamo un inversione new
team bertolani ma mi dice di fare lo
scorpio io ti di vento segno zodiacale
questo piede diventa un pungiglione
velenoso zac emerso rispetto a noi è
comunque eravamo al nostro primo
allenamento lui ci aveva un altro
allenamento alle spalle ed è gay
parliamoci chiaro enrico l'ho visto male
su quel palo
[Applauso]
le gambe
[Musica]
il declino di un uomo qui si vede
[Applauso]
[Musica]
si no
lo so ma giuro lo spazio
noi
e poi ho superato le mie aspettative
non pensavo di poter fare così male era
scontato ragazzi apro altro ecco qua se
vede nella pole dance dovresti essere
colpito dalle immagini ecco forse qui si
tratta di essere colpiti ma in modo
traumatico
[Risate]
la cosa interessante è che lì per lì non
è che te ne frega tanto di come sei
conciato è una cosa positiva secondo me
per il corpo non ti interessa in quel
momento come appari ti interessa
riuscire a fare quella roba che ti è
stata detta che è molto meno associabile
al mignottone che lo stigma potrebbe
affibbiare a questo tipo di sport ma
invece molto più legato a una
prestazione fisica sportiva è difficile
o molto il movimento secondo me sensuale
e quindi spiega coreografia che ha fatto
danza coreografie
io ho fatto clown po di classica sono
curioso di vedere come si comporteranno
gianmarco enrico gianmarco che era lo
stesso flow di jack skeleton nightmare
before christmas che tutto in stop
motion gianmarco me l'aspettavo peggio
ma anche al balletto in realtà perché
lui è uno stoccafisso e invece quella
gamba sinuosa lunga ho detto quasi quasi
un pensierino dai parla muse chiaro il
balletto impresentabile
non è giusto non subito
che hanno generato
[Musica]
vai in piena
noi siamo un po la testa sarebbe stata
la fine
se si va oltre i limiti che un dolore
cane vedevo pure i peli dell'ascella
strappati cia una barbarie non so come
faccia a chi pratica questo sport a
sopportare una roba simile perché
veramente dolorosissima e io non è che
sono uno che sai piange perché gli fa
gli fanno così ho fatto sport un po più
pesanti tutti ci sono trovati lividi e
quant'altro io sto una crema
all'inizio pensavo di dovermi sottoporre
a un'umiliazione davanti alla nazione o
poi facendoli data l'ho trovato anche
piuttosto divertente lo rifarei
al momento il maestro si usano non pane
in casa quindi dove netto non è talmente
andare a casa di la linea quindi non so
se lo rifarei perché non lo voglio mai
più vedere quella ragazza
la regna in candombe basso dai